have you guys ever had pregnancy scares
with women you were dating I mean I'm
sure there I'm kind of yeah I've had
like condoms break or like we kind of go
up like inside like that yeah or like
not being used right or just like an
unused condom
I mean someone had a story about getting
pregnant even after they took the
morning-after pill yeah so it's like
some some babies just like be rolling
but then you're like that's a baby I
want a key because you survived the
morning-after pill and he just like
started using that word just me yeah his
brother's my brother is yeah that gives
you a right why are so easy with you
saying the R word
sure
[Music]
I went on a vacation on my dad this
weekend and we got back from the airport
at like maybe three in the morning and
my mom had left us a sandwich but the
thing that my brother is like if there's
food in the house he he'll eat the whole
bag so you have to hide right max or you
know what does he have actually he has
like severe autism so he's like
nonverbal but um but me and my dad has a
moment we're like we wanted chips with
our sandwich and we were just like
looking around the house at 3:00 in the
morning trying to figure out where my
mom could have hid chips so if he gets
into something he'll make himself sick
by eating all of it
yeah he'll eat the whole bag and then if
you try to take it away from him maybe
he's just good luck how old is he he's
20 he just turned 28 okay so he's
younger than you yeah what was that like
growing up what it's fine when did he
start showing signs of it like when he
was 2 okay he was like a normal baby -
right what were the first signs do you
remember he would like talk as a baby he
would say like mom and dad and then he
just kind of like shut off and I
remember like when my mom was like your
brother is autistic I thought it was
weird cause he was like normal so I
didn't think it was gonna be that right
and then what's been the worst of it
just like um you know tamp it is he ever
gonna be able to live on his own I don't
think so
oh that sucks yeah like 36 who like what
does he do 28 what's he doing now with
his life uh he just kind of hangs out at
home does he have a job or is he able to
not he had one but then I think he like
grabbed a lady or something yeah I just
fire he used to Reb is working oh it's
good one time to make fun of a retarded
person oh I hope you feel good about
yourself that's a human being with
feelings retarded
I might squeeze a rabbit squeeze a rap
my brother gets me to buy a rabbit does
he know who you I mean obviously he
knows who can he talk at all yeah a
little bit a little better questions
yeah yeah yeah do you see him often yeah
when I go home right yeah I'm sorry I'm
having so many questions about this but
it is kind of fascinating do you have
other siblings yeah two other siblings
and do they know like what causes it
probably I probably have some a little
bit of robably might you have something
going oh my god what do you mean I don't
know I mean you're hyper intelligent you
write really crazy like I feel like
there's some form of there's no one's
ever called me hyper intelligent I think
you are in terms of joke writing like
you look and you can't write jokes like
you write without being smart and some
weird way like you have a smart about
you some great jokes but but yeah I feel
like there's there's something spectra
me about your and I will like like and
the way you behave and interact with
people people can't make eye contact I'm
making eye contact no there was an
entire where Mike Mike wouldn't look my
cohost in the eyes for an entire hour
because because we did it but we did a
show about limp Biskit and I came on to
talk about limp Biskit because I'm a fan
and then the whole time Tommy was like
this music sucks I hate it but the whole
pockets he was pretending to like limp
Biskit okay just a little bit quiet
instead I felt a little man if someone
betrays you you get so we're very
similar in that way like if you get hurt
do you go after but like do you how do
you handle with someone I don't have a
lot of enemies but I feel like if I did
I would I would destroy them you had to
have if someone hurts you come after
them in like
weird ways which we'll get to later on
in the show because I hurt you
and you came after me in the weirdest
weirdest way no it's not you some would
say it was how do you say that is not
true I don't think I came after you I
think I wanted to I think you wanted to
hurt me I wanna know really yeah
okay well we'll talk about it Mike and I
have some history and he definitely did
something which I do not begrudge you
because I have done
dirty dirty things to men who have hurt
me and and and men who have rejected me
I've done some mean things I'm not proud
of the only thing I did was I went to
your garbage at one time so Mike and I
make out in Atlantic City it's just a
casual fun thing I was just like oh I
can just like make out not for me it
wasn't casual and fun for me I did not
know that it wasn't casual and fun for
Mike I did of course I had a feeling
Mike had a crush on me because he can't
really hide how he is he just like is
you know you just you're not really good
at masking your emotions like right now
what's you want to punch me in the arm
no I don't want to punch you and I was
like JC I'm telling you like I was mad
when I when I texted you that night when
you were doing that taping with with
Schumer and Feinstein you know I don't
remember I blew you off yeah but you
were taping a TV thing yeah text me back
and there was no service and the thing
and I was like stay the away from
me forever you said that's amazing I
think so yeah yeah yeah I was there were
a couple months where I was like you
need to like lose my number
you're crazy and I don't like I do
remember there were a couple times where
I was a little bit like he's not he's
I've upset this person that like I'm
scared of his anger a little bit well
I'm sorry about that
well that's okay because now I realize
you put your anger into sketches and not
like actual violence so I don't care
what you what the kind of things you
write okay so we made out I go back to
st. Louis and and I didn't realize the
he that he thought this was now gonna be
something more but you were pretty
you're pretty like honest about that and
I remember I was like after that
happened I was like this is the woman
I'm gonna marry like my life is I've
been a loser my whole life but things
are going to turn around no yeah I
thought that way too when if I've hooked
up with a guy that I've that I really
like project all of these things onto it
and then that I've never felt those
feelings since then but I remember I was
I was with Mike Lawrence at KFC and it
was right into the double down sandwich
and come out do you remember those yeah
they're like a sandwich without bread so
it was two it's two piece of fried
chicken yes so the the bun is the
chicken and there's bacon and cheese and
mayonnaise in the middle of huh and I
was eating one of those sandwiches being
like oh yeah she's just so great you
know and I'm gonna go see her in hawk
because you were in Hartford yeah the
following weekend yeah I get this text
it's like uh yeah Mike sorry to be blunt
but I really just want to be friends I
had to go back to eating my double down
sandwich Mike Lawrence I'm sorry back to
the sewer I live in we'll put a movie on
[Laughter]
feeling the need to write that text you
because you had written me the day after
we had made out because I flew out early
that next morning I think this lter
please there's like 40 of them I
probably I'd like a 6:00 a.m. flight or
something I went right from making out
to being like I have to pack and leave
you can have my hotel room you can sleep
here I think that's how it kind of went
yeah I think it did yeah so I I but the
next morning I land and I remember I was
on a run that I got a text
oh boy it's all coming back I got a text
I can still smell your hair yeah it was
something like that
that was like last night was it was
sweat here's the thing if you were
really into it that would be a nice text
again so much fun with you and then you
respond oh it wasn't just out of nowhere
I'm sorry it could have been but it
probably was couched but that was I just
remember that being the line that was
like oh no he really likes me because so
that was like that was kind of like you
know whatever but you were honest about
that but then a month later this was I
think May 1st 2010 no but it was like a
couple months later right yeah you were
like I'm coming back to New York I can't
wait to see you and I was like alright
time to like you know start working out
and like I'm gonna be a new person yeah
you know and we all can relate because
and I and I wish the you know I wish
looking back on it I should have been
like you know hey I really like you and
maybe maybe it's gonna be a while till
we can till we can be friends yeah
because I think I just wanted to go
right into friendship which I was
talking to Ian about this last night
about there's any young men listening
out there don't become a Men's Rights
Act be honest about how you feel point
to make actually because when women or
I've been in the same position where
I've really liked a guy and I've been
like I like you and I want to be with
you and he's like I just want to be a
treasure our friendship too much and
I've been like they said the guy said
yeah and I've been like okay oh that's
fine yeah I'm cool with that and I am
filled with resentment hanging out with
him from there on out and then he's
talking about girls with me and
and treating me like a friend and it
just you need to take a break if you
like someone don't take the friend card
because you can be their friend
eventually and you're not a mean person
to reject their friendship but just say
I just think I need a little bit of
space because you cannot jump right from
liking someone to being their friend and
that person is gonna really try to
friendzone you and really make it seem
like I want to make good boundaries here
so they're gonna talk about guys they're
into her girls they're into and it's
going to be painful so I was gonna be
painful and you're gonna be like it's
gonna be a weird dynamic like you'll be
like showing up with bagels at 9:00 in
the morning being like you know or
you'll be yeah you'll when did you show
no I'm just saying like you do all these
things have you degrade yourself you
think that maybe you know in some way
and then secretly you're like later if
we hang out she'll realize she was like
sleeping on my couch all the time and I
play buck hunter Pro and then chill I
mean I've been on the recently on the
other side of this where guy was like I
just I just cherish our friendship so
much and and I and I was smart enough to
know like we're not really gonna be
friends like I care I like you too much
and I don't want to hear about other
girls so I've I stepped away but then
there are also times where in recent
times where I've felt like guys getting
a crush on guy friends getting a crush
on me and I really try to like put a
line in the sand before it's even called
out you know that you kind of like the
attention a little bit yes of course as
a woman first of all I like the
friendship I like having a guy and
having a guy like you they are more
they're in agreement with you all the
time they they do whatever you want to
do you know like when a guy likes you
it's it's a good energy as long as he
doesn't actually make a move
do you agree with I gave you a ride I
gave you a ride at my moving van yeah I
like and I wasn't taking advantage of it
I was honestly trying to just have a
friend but it's just a it's a
it's a tricky situation and as a woman
who knows when a guy likes you you
should really try to make it very clear
that that is not what it is so that they
don't get to the point where they're
like I like birth just so they know that
there's no chance I mean but then you
look at it like yeah I mean I I lost a
bunch of weight my teeth got whiter I
started showering a better man you know
who I was hanging out with who I could
tell like me you know it will never
happen ever and if we're gonna be
friends you need to accept that was like
a challenge and literally eight years
later I had the same another guy tell me
the same thing he was like it will never
happen and that was so freeing to me to
here never you don't feel like it'll
never happen between us right I mean who
knows a lot of like the kids but I think
really because when you kick the can
down the road and you go not now you
know if you're gonna be into someone and
you obviously can't predict how things
are gonna change by a while going it was
like so intense and she kind of led me
on a lot and we like kissed a bunch and
then she's like I only want to be your
friend I was like you need to think tell
yourself yes we will never know was like
okay but that is a tricky situation
because that girl was making out with
you some girls will like send naked
pictures because it's like he's my guy
friend and I want this I want this it's
really not nice to do and we should all
be a little bit more aware of other
people's feelings and and and try to
empathize with when someone has a crush
on you which I should have done a better
job of instead of trying to jump into
friendship with good old Mike Racine
because tonight really is a good thing
it's very hard to jump into friendship
with me my dog so I what moving forward
I just I think we just didn't we weren't
friends anymore like I just think that
you're
anger about not having our relationship
what you wanted it to be I could just
feel when I was around you I remember
one time we went out to dinner and I
bought you dinner and I was really
resentful because I don't think you
thanks me soon enough or something it
was really petty of me but I just
remember being like poor Johnny no I
said I was gonna take you out to lunch
and then you pulled your wallet out
uh-huh who cares I remember you but I
remember how much it was is this
ridiculous it was like their dollars for
a chicken plate at olive tree no it was
a different place but I remember being
like I just and I was broke $17 on a guy
who's my friend I was so furious and so
I think and I was like well I gotta get
something out of this so I'm just doing
pull-ups like Travis Bickle like
eventually are you touching me Mike and
I definitely go our separate ways then
let's see May 29th 2011 I get an email
from Mike and I don't have the original
email here hold on yes I do hold on let
me just pull this up really quick
because I want to see what you wrote to
me because Tom sent me what he had but
it's what you sent you to your brother
you and your brother co-wrote this
sketch together and I have an email from
my brother being like hey this is really
funny
maybe we could punch it up a little bit
but you got something here yeah he's
like my uh I don't know okay so I can't
find it
yeah like a movie character of like a
yeah like a shitty uh you know sidekick
oh here it is hey Nikki my brother and I
wrote this sketch and there's a part in
it for you if you like it let me know he
rewrote it and reformatted it in his I'm
not gonna say that word blank little
film school way so I can't figure out
how to change it but the only thing I
take out is the line at the I don't use
that word anymore by the way okay well
you used to work it doesn't matter
so you said check out the sketch do you
want to be in it is essentially what the
sketch was now I'd love to read the
sketch together all of us yeah
quick parts great because there's four
parts I think oh great so I don't know
there's no there's only three why don't
you have a and plate me so Mike sent me
the sketch he he asked me to be in it
I'm gonna play Nikki because there's a
part written and it have Ian play me so
I can do commentary is gonna play Mike
Racine in this sketch I'm gonna play
myself which by the way Mike made it
clear after I got upset about the sketch
this was not about me okay even the
characters names into my project so it
feels more personal and also there's the
part of Steve which is your real
brother's name too I love this is
actually formatted well - it's like a
final draft I asked my mom for $200 to
buy final drafts like this so Mike asked
me to be in the sketch and this is the
sketch okay now I just can I just say
again I I don't remember being mad at
you when I wrote this yeah I know you
think it's like some kind of revenge
thing we start with the title Wow
wait that's so weird the first action is
Nikki a Dumbo okay Faden interior
writing books tour day Nikki late 20s
browses the bookstore what are we all
laughing at that for well you probably
in your mid-20s then right oh yeah let's
this was 77 okay late 20s that's fine
Nikki late 20s browses the bookstore she
sees Steve early 20s a familiar face hi
Steve
Oh Mike weird seeing you here why cuz I
can't read Nikki's cellphone rings you
know opening oh she checks who's calling
oh my god Steve this is so weird your
brother is
don't ad-lib bake it better
Oh your brother is calling me she
answers the phone hey Mike
interior Mike's apartment Mike Lai's is
on the couch in his boxers in a guinea
t-shirt hey Nicky just thought I'd call
see how you doing
intercut between bookstore and Mike's
apartment I'm I'm good I'm with your
brother right now oh yeah what are you
guys doing we banged our banging it's
awesome
Mike can't believe what he's hearing
Steve it's a whispering Andy key I don't
think that's a good idea
Oh Mike also your brother he's awesome
in the sack cut to black it's fine Simon
Nicky okay so clearly the first scene is
me playing a joke on Mike that I'm with
his brother and I'm like I'm gonna
pretend him yes I'm having sex with your
brother by book story yes Faden exterior
street corner
a few days later Nicky walks down the
street by herself approaching her is
Steve pushing Mike in a wheelchair
Mike's movements are jerky and he makes
incoherent noises torture his head his
pant it's Steve pushes the wheelchair up
to Nikki hi Nikki oh my god what
oh you mean Mike Nikki kneels down to
Mike's eye level what happened he can't
understand you Nikki he's permanently
retarded Nikki springs to her feet
what yeah he tried to kill himself oh my
it's actually your fault you knew he
really liked you Dicky after that joke
you made he got a gun and tried to kill
himself but he didn't die sounds messed
up but I wish he had I mean okay I can't
even defend this
I think this might be bad writing but I
think about it Mike please okay this is
direction Mike plays plays with the pool
of saliva forming on his chest yeah so
now he's retarded forever and I have to
take care of him what about your parents
they're really busy boy starts to yell
incoherently at Steve who leans out and
you wanna yell in completely what is it
Mike are you hungry do you want to drink
some chicken noodle soup out of a straw
Mike try to use your words what do you
want oh you want me to wipe the drool
off your face Steve wipes Mike's face
it's okay it's okay Mike there you go
you're so brave Nicky buries her face in
her hands and starts to sob clothes on
Nicky's tortured guilt-ridden face wider
view of Mike standing up out of his
wheelchair taking the bandage off of his
head and looking angry that's what you
get for with my heart okay he
turns and briskly briskly walks away
Steve thing is like you never see
someone's earlier work earned him in
ways that he wrote all those good books
but you never saw his short story after
stuff you've never made it it got lost
and you take a journey as a creative
person and you gotta just put words on
the page if you want to be a writer
after Steve spits at Nicky here it says
Steve says bitch Mike wait up Steve runs
up to catch up with Mike while pushing
the wheelchair that's a funny image he's
like chasing at me with the wheelchair
oh I like this
sounds for the has not heard this before
or acted in this team what do you make
of this sketch that he asked me to be in
and I believe I wrote back and said I
don't want to be in your sketch my I
want to find the email that I wrote to
you that's not important believe it is
also called
[Laughter]
so you thought this worked out your
anger towards me had the balls to put my
feelings on to the person who hurt me
yeah I don't think that's passive no
aggressive would have been Nikki you
hurt me I'm really angry at you that's
that's something that the guys have to
learn you know is like just dealing with
rejection intelligent healthier way yeah
cuz it's gonna happen a lot I think it's
a good idea to write sketches in movies
and songs when you're mad at someone and
you want to work it out like that would
have been a fine sketch to write and not
send me right just don't use the
character's name Nikki also I had a my
best friend in high school was blamed
for a guy's suicide because he wrote a
note he killed himself and he wrote a
note and said I did this because of you
so very triggering for me Mike thanks a
lot but it was true a lot of times like
guy got his point across huh
[Music]
you